Wow, I am really surprised by this paper.
You see, we know from an earlier paper that
in virtual worlds, glittery materials like
this, and brushed aluminum surfaces like this
can be rendered with ray tracing based techniques.
Light simulations on a computer, if you will.
That is wonderful, but I am not surprised
by that.
What I am surprised about is this paper.
This one does something truly incredible.
Hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars because
here is a simulated ceramic material with
multiple layers, with fingerprints, with dust,
with smudges, oh my goodness, I am going to
pass out.
Look at that!
It can also simulate the glitter on the plastic
handle here, and the metal part of the cheese
slicer is simulated down to the tiniest little
scratches of the surface.
Absolutely loving it.
Note that these are all computer simulations
of virtual worlds.
Not real photographs.
This is beauty that only a proper computer
graphics research paper can offer.
Unmatched.
And for the teapot, the metal handle was also
something else.
When I started my PhD in light transport simulation
in 2013, I did not think that we will be able
to do this kind of graphics in my lifetime,
and about 10 years later, here it is.
I can’t believe it.
So, with this technique, we can capture real
materials, and layer by layer, put them into
a computer program where we can simulate them…well,
how quickly can we simulate them?
I bet we have to wait for hours for every
single image, right?
Well, not quite.
Let me explain.
This is a neural network-based technique,
where we take a stupendously large amount
of material reflectance data, for 40 billion
different training samples.
And all this takes…wait, what?
4-5 hours per material to train on one commodity
graphics card?
How is that even possible?
Well, let’s pop the hood and take a closer
look.
Oh yes.
The neural network is tiny, very lightweight
presumably for quick training and running,
we will have a look at that in a moment.
However, it is compressing an enormous amount
of data, that is, 2.5 billion latent parameters.
And after the training is done, we can use
these materials quickly for as long as we
wish.
Now, in summary, the neural network that is
behind this is a tiny, lightweight encoder
that understands and compresses this enormous
amount of reflectance information down into
something smaller, more manageable.
So, we have two more important questions left.
One, is it as good as a true, reference simulation?
I can’t wait, let’s have a look together.
This is what it looks like compared to the
reference simulation.
Now, have a look here.
You see, this difference does not mean that
the new technique is less sparkly, it’s
not worse.
It is actually better, because it has less
noise, something that is inherent to real
light transport simulations.
Ray tracers, if you will.
You can witness it on a simple diffuse surface
too which is not meant to be sparkly at all.
Wow, this means that it is nearly indistinguishable
from the true reference simulation, and is
even faster.
So, how much faster?
Well, get this, it is 2-10 times faster than
the reference solution, which is incredible.
So, question number two.
What does this speed look like?
Well, look!
When we move the camera around in real time,
we get a really noisy image, but, look!
As we stop, we have more time to simulate
more rays to clean up this image, which happens
almost immediately.
There is still noise in these images, but
don’t forget, we have many powerful noise
filtering techniques that are specifically
tailored for ray tracing algorithms, so I
am very hopeful that one or two more papers
down the line, and we will be able to do this
in real time.
Yes, that’s right.
I didn’t think this would be possible in
my lifetime, and through the power of computer
graphics, AI research, and human ingenuity,
it is not only possible, but it will be possible
in real time.
Pinch me.
What a time to be alive!
This was Two Minute Papers with Dr. Károly
Zsolnai-Fehér.
Subscribe if you wish to see more.